you've said to your mother you wish she
was dead
I've seen my mom do very hurtful things
and I've gotten to the point where I was
like then I already what probably from
all that pain I've been through in my
life you thought it was okay to have
abusive behavior around me continuously
I was totally wrong I dropped all the
charges from the police officers against
they were bogus
my mom was arrested because she threw
something at me that provoked our fights
Chanda go take anger management courses
for her abuse you me up in my face the
laws here's the upset feeling someone
lies like you want us a lot I don't lie
totally against what I believe in oh
yeah I think it's what I belong to and
that's why I don't lie police officer
had a gun to your head cuz my whole face
was bleeding oh it was not you had a
little tiny drop of blood right here how
to show you how did she get some a
little fish headlock tell me she's gonna
break my fingers and kill me cops called
guns to someone said guns to people's
head what I'm learning about we we
thought you got abused your daughters
you got
this is stupid-ass [ __ ] everything if
there's the Edit on and I can't pin
Daiki I dig - Farah have you want me to
be someone Hospital
[Music]